time to talk with Massa Johnson who's
now in his sixth season at Hamburg the
last time we talked was seven years ago
when he was an up-and-coming youngster
who had just been selected for the
national squad then came a short stint
at Byam the midfielder has played under
a total of sixteen different coaches
nine at Hamburg alone we want to know
what yon ssin thinks about impermanence
and what it feels like to be hamburg's
anchor point in the club seemingly
ever-changing universe Sansa you haven't
had to clean out your locker in the past
few years but you've certainly watched
plenty of coaches do it I know dolls
ones in yes well yes it happened a few
times back when i was at Gladbach and
now at Humber kind of excess oil then
there was one at Bayern exit though I
was only there for a year and am I have
to admit that in the course of my career
I've started to view the position of
coach that's pretty precarious though at
Hamburg it's been taken to the next
level that's what's having so many
coaches good for your career or more of
a negative thing hmm oh come on e I
don't think I can't really say exactly
for me personally in the situation I
experienced especially as a younger
player let's just say it's normal to
need a certain amount of stability where
you're playing that's the best case
scenario though that is the optimal only
a few clubs manage to make that happen
and I personally really don't have to
have a perfectly healthy structure
around me in order to perform guns
kizuna spoke to us yep although it's
been a rough road to travel at times
I've managed to make my way back into
the national team regardless of what's
been going on in my club that's
something that emphasizes my desire to
succeed and shows that a player can
influence a lot all on his own he
doesn't have to blame things on the
coach or on the club I learned that from
my father actually he always taught me
that in the real world nobody gets to
choose their boss in bowls Lehman and am
i invade Kansas Canadian chef also i was
very surely it would have been helpful
to have a coach for a little longer my
fine Finny much of this it certainly is
for a team the clubs that are most
successful up
of that they can show that they've
worked to reach goals nothing is
short-term there it's all about solid
development dortmund is the classic
example of it and Byron has been doing
it for decades the same coach is always
in charge there for a few years at a
time about my your coaches have changed
so often do you think you know now when
the right coach has come along I gave my
knuckle as I said sophisticates from the
LA outside I have to say I'm a little
jaded by the topic after all the changes
because sometimes the effects were
short-lived but that isn't always just
down to the coach it's the whole package
because all the coaches that I had here
at Hamburg were very good very
experienced coaches when things like
this happen this cluster of changes then
it's never the fault of single players
or coaches there's our Father let you
know it's always a problem with the
overall concept boy for done Disney
dines so that needs to be looked at and
thought about I problem descansen
concepts and that's the desk in assaults
abutting yummy all my gazelle you once
said that it's like trying to build a
house while constantly hiring a new
architect on my annoying architect born
yeah yes I think that both coaches and
players want to come into a structure
where they know what's expected of them
where the procedures are clear 20 cooks
will always spoil the broth sponsors
Christendom the club needs to focus on
developing a philosophy that implements
direct channels of communication and
responsibilities from the top flight all
the way through to the youth teams home
w lincoln what does a house look like
after so many different architects
rainbow well it's going to be less than
ideal you can see that of the
surroundings often expressed as fan
dissatisfaction because they have a very
good sense of whether what's been built
will hold up and what's fun that doesn't
mean you always have to win mosbach
that's how you just wanna among given
Muslim okay so if the club isn't a
constant then the only thing left is
your responsibility as an individual
player say about English yeah absolutely
fun fun it to be responsible in constant
so this exactly that's
the point i think that players have to
internalize that concept first before
they can move on to something else I've
noticed a certain mentality that's crept
in at Hamburg over the last few years in
the draw for the German Cup I'll hear
things like any team as long as it isn't
buyer but there's nothing cooler no
better game than to play against Bayern
in the evening and if you play above
your own level which have to do to have
a chance but it's possible if unlikely
anyway if in the end you beat Bayern
then you have a shot of the cup that's
what I don't understand not this if we
play vows Borg at home we can be
satisfied with a draw this way of
thinking that's crept in here I don't
share it I'm too ambitious for it and I
don't understand that I think that's for
station